there's also a discussion to be had
about
the more mainstream you become the more
new eyes you invite to yourself and if
they're not
used to what you say if they're starting
to realize how much sway you have or how
much influence you have you bring in a
whole bunch of eyes that would normally
never want to watch your stuff and they
come in with that criticism i don't even
think it's that much of a hit piece i
think because he's gotten so much
recognition now people are like i don't
like this dude i'm gonna start looking
through his [ __ ] to see if i can find
any dirt and then they started watching
a couple podcasts and like yo he said
the n word there i could super cut this
i don't even think it's as calculated as
that i don't think it has to
i think just the more your name's out
there the more people are going to look
you up and if people don't like what
you're saying they're just going to find
things to go after you especially if
you're attached to an institution
because then they can put the pressure
on the institution well that's what
they're doing 100 that's what they do
but it's just it's just i understand
that you don't feel like it's calculated
i just use a calculated thing because
it's us
yo the timing is super satisfying man
but i'm about to say
but
did you see the the thread on your tweet
no
come on bro i don't look at my mentions
of your own terrifying
[ __ ] like when i open twitter and i get
like a lot of mentions i'm like oh here
it is bro there's a thread on your tweet
with 18 000 likes oh really explaining
who did it oh who do they say this is
like uh like a long thread but basically
and i don't know again if this is true
or not but this is what they piece
together they basically say
uh they
look at all the people that are
propagating all the initial tweets and
they say it's a twitter page called
patriot takes
this is the whole porno thing right
okay so patriot takes puts out all these
things if you look at patriot takes bio
they're partnered with a company called
midas touch yeah and then midas touch is
a professional political organization
they're a democrat super pac run by
three brothers
and you can basically like find the
people and they're basically just
getting like unlimited funding and i
don't really understand how super pacs
work but my understanding is like it's a
political tool you can just get
unlimited money to fund campaigns so you
can't put money into politicians pockets
but you can hire a super pac they can
get unlimited money so it basically acts
as like a financial buffer between the
rich people and the corporations and the
politicians that's actually making the
influence yeah that's how like george
soros can just put in
endless millions to support all these
tiny little but it also allows it also
allows the pack to control the decisions
of the candidate so if a candidate wants
the money they got to do what the pac
wants certain promises exactly and it
goes both ways there's republican super
pacs and democrats who are packaged
right so people are pointing to patriot
takes in their connection with midas
touch as
the
basically it's coming from like
unspecified democrat funding
now now portnoy did like a youtube live
yeah yesterday and uh
he and i think he referenced the tweet
of mine and then he was talking to these
guys and then what was the outcome
because it felt like at least from the
reaction on on the internet that
no no clear like victor there was no
clear
irresponsible party
i mean the one thing that you can watch
and just assume is that midas touch
isn't responsible
for cutting together the compilation
video of rogan yeah it was also the same
one that was done for uh portnoy and
business insider like you can i mean i
don't know the proof but you can kind of
feel that almost portnoy believe that
and then it led into his belief to say
tell me that you guys are part of this
group that is trying to really bring
people down because porno thought there
was connective tissue between the hip
piece on him and the videos that went
out on him and this piece on rogan right
so he was trying to be like yo there's
one party trying to take all of us down
let's point the finger at these guys see
if it's them but it looked like the guys
offended themselves well yeah and he
just didn't have enough proof i mean it
was pretty impromptu like it was from a
couple tweets earlier in the day time to
like a midnight new york time like live
session and he tried to pivot towards uh
but yeah he did name check you that
he kind of saw oh [ __ ] this is a uh you
know a strategic power play and a hit
piece and
yeah but i think it's two two pronged if
it is the super pack that's behind it
because one they get the i guess like
clout and business like resume of saying
like yo we took down a massive political
player and like a
you know a broadcaster so if you're
going to try to like put money into a
super pac this is the one you want to
put into because we have the actual
influence oh yeah and secondly if you
look at rogan's endorsements in the past
even if he's endorsed democrats it
hasn't been like establishment democrats
right like doors
democrats that people
in the democrat party probably are not
as big of fans of so you would say the
democratic establishment has the most to
gain by silence and rogan
i guess he's not going to support the
people that they want to put in power i
don't know if they have the most again
necessarily like i think news has a lot
to gain and i don't know if you can
equate or well that's the other one
which one you can say is the most
there's a bunch of people who stand to
gain from it and they're gonna pile
right the [ __ ] up on of course and
that's why it's almost like the perfect
storm if you're trying to get him out of
here because all you need to do is light
the match conservative media might have
something to gain from it
i don't think
go ahead i was going to say without
trump in the building i think this
becomes a great focal point like i feel
like there's always a new story on rogan
everywhere oh yeah they've made him the
new trump right right which i think
is not the most convenient because rogan
is not outlandish enough for them to
like fight back or to be combative so it
doesn't create a great back and forth
that stays on tv but as long as they can
come up with these stories they'll turn
them out as long as they can and he is
white male straight yeah right said some
racist stuff says edgy things
potentially anti-vaxx says some
controversial stuff in regards to
pandemic yeah perfect vocal point
because they got all the clips that they
need perfect focal point it's money it's
money i guarantee you the stories that
they write on rogan are probably their
highest rated stories 100 and i don't
even think that nobody has to benefit
from
from
it's not from rogan being here um
because
rogan kind of encourages people to talk
yeah have a different opinion yeah
people to be able to converse people to
be in the middle and what what political
party hates people in the middle people
that are nuanced nuance kills
the political thing yeah yeah you gotta
go on one side or you gotta go on the
other you gotta be all the way blue or
all the way red god forbid you think for
yourself
right like yeah yeah if he's able to
just be like no maybe they got something
and maybe they got something and let's
meet in the middle both these
[ __ ] they hate that [ __ ] so i
think that's i think that's that's
that's the thing on the other side
though and i think it's important to go
to be fair i've seen a lot of people
criticize rogan for the simple fact that
when he has these more controversial
guests his own biases come in and he
doesn't offer any pushback on the guests
who may say some wacky stuff because
there have been some guests he's had on
who said some stuff that's just
absolutely nonsense yeah yeah right
and i and and to that i'm always like
yeah you know what there is a bicep even
me when i watch the podcast i can see
that but i don't look to rogan to be the
unbiased source the same way when i go
on cnn i'm not expecting them to be like
well i can understand the anti-vaxxers
the same way when i go like right
everybody's got their i think there's
this idea of like the unbiased
individual or the unbiased reporter or
the unbiased news network it doesn't
exist dude not that i know a fellow
[ __ ] supreme court
they're literally hired to be unbiased
and they vote the party line every
single time and that's why it's such a
big [ __ ] deal when they're when one
is going to get nominated who might be
like a republican or has certain beliefs
it's like it shouldn't matter what their
party is no you're literally just
looking at the constitution and making
your decision based on the consequences
you're supposed to do your job so their
political values shouldn't matter out
the windows well right on the paper
condition but nobody reads the [ __ ]
terms but you know that's a good point
like we don't i don't want rogue to be
neutral just be you dog no like he never
said hey i'm the neutral guy yeah and
i'm just giving it information like have
the people on you're interested in yo if
you're interested in native americans
have a guy on who wrote a [ __ ] book
about native americans you don't own
nobody anything no right cnn fox news
the people the people that come out
there and they just go hey we are the
truth
you owe us some truth yo yeah and if you
don't we could be upset
but the guy doing a podcast that's
talking to scientists and is curious
about things
he owes his he owes us his curiosity
that's exactly what a podcast is yeah
you might be listening to it and while
you're on your laptop like oh they just
talked about this let me google and do
yeah
these like they forgot the whole yeah
yeah god forbid it worked out yeah he
forgot about it the minute that that
[ __ ] started to get her numbers
the minute that people started i'm not
gonna look at you i'm gonna look at them
because you [ __ ] up but that's not on
joe rogan that's all on them on all the
media that [ __ ] up and do some [ __ ]
up [ __ ]
do you think there's a bit of
programming like in the sense that
whether it's this or whether it's the
fact that people watch a two-minute clip
and they come to a knee-jerk reaction is
there not a bit of programming mentally
where our minds are just not capable
of
we we have to simplify things i can't
get to know everybody like i'm not going
to watch a 10-minute video on al or a
one-hour video on how to know if i see
two minute clip like you're a piece of
[ __ ] to me because i don't have time to
do the extra research yeah i don't think
our brains can look at every incident
and wait to make a judgment right
we had a discussion about this yeah yeah
so like i'm reading this book right now
roger ailes like the dude that basically
like ran fox from like behind the scenes
and he's like
evil capitalist guy but like also kind
of a genius at the same time like a
tricky tricky character yeah basically
he was so he was the first guy to like
made politics entertainment on tv and
was like yo make the tv thing for people
and he has a quote in the book where
he's like bro thinking is hard yeah it
is hard to think let the tv think
people want to just digest information
that's already worked out i mean that's
my frustration right now with news is
like i don't trust any of it so i find
myself checking out of information yes
right like i actually will go to like my
friends for takes
i go to my friend going what is your
take on this even if it's not based in
fact or anything i'm just like what do
you feel because your feeling is
probably just as accurate as the
[ __ ] i'm gonna get on msnbc
or fox news right so
if people want to remove themselves from
that thinking process and they find a
place where they believe the truth is
yeah they'll start to just convince
themselves that that's the truth right
it is what it is so i understand like
people feeling maybe misled in that
regard but like that's the human that's
the human reaction that's a human
instinct let's do as little work as
possible to get the most information
that we can yes right
it's like that's why books exist right
oh this guy's an expert on that he
figured it all out okay i'm going to
digest this book because i don't want to
go to college for three years and then
you're just going for [ __ ] and then have
a dark trip you wanted some real [ __ ]
i'll give a [ __ ] about it i'm trying to
figure out a story i go on youtube i go
let me see if i've preached already
figured out this goddamn story
you know how many people watch your [ __ ]
because they're like i don't want to
research this [ __ ] i've been preach
researching yeah they did the work you
guys did the work you know we did google
yeah
when we were doing the rants bro the
research was the hardest part writing
the jokes is fun getting in a room
talking that [ __ ] etc but writing the
[ __ ] research paper going in there
reading the [ __ ] articles talking to
experts yeah yeah but the news don't
want to do that no more they want [ __ ] i
want ric flair yeah yeah everybody loves
really
yeah yeah tucker is entertaining
laughs
they want they want they want that and
the news cannot do that anymore and they
see rogan with his numbers and then he
gets all the publicity that we can't get
yeah all that money we want that money
you